hi I'm Rick Hannigan my talk is on
welcome challenges and I'll be speaking
specifically about developing challenges
and some of the challenges one
encounters and putting together a more
complicated cloud application
hello everyone I'm Rick Hannigan I'm a
software developer at Wolfram research
today I'm going to be talking about
Wolfram challenges how many here are not
familiar with welcome challenges okay
all right good news is I will be
covering briefly what it is from a
user's perspective but the main focus of
this talk is could is going to be on the
developers perspective like some of the
things that I found useful when putting
together this sort of cloud application
so those that are familiar with fulsome
challenges as anyone here submitted
solutions anyone on the leader board not
you all right okay so like I said well
I'll do a brief overview of Wolfram
challenges so everyone has an idea of
what it is and what it's for and then
I'll talk about how some of how some of
it works behind the scenes which is what
I called the stock with the content
management side of it and then I'll be
talking about some of the deployment
things okay so what is Wolfram
challenges it's a website it looks like
this rather than me explaining it it's
probably best if I just show how it
works so it's a collection of challenges
which is a word you're going to be
really sick of by the end of this and it
won't even sound like a word anymore so
it's basically a bunch of programming
puzzles that's meant to be fun
and to challenge you and basically you
can try to solve these and to sharpen
your skills practice and if you have a
competitive type and want to get on a
leaderboard for how good of a solution
you come up with
that's that also works so we've got a
whole bunch of them
I think like 100-something now I'll just
show one real quick
this one's super easy you click on
challenge and you can see the
description
there we go yeah so this one's pretty
easy spoiler alert I'm about to solve it
so if anyone doesn't want to know the
solution and close your eyes
so you can you can solve these in the
desktop or in the cloud
they're both notebooks I'm going to
solve this in the cloud
so the same thing we just saw except now
it's a notebook
so I defined the function that asked me
for and you hit submit and if you did it
right it'll come back and tell you you
were successful or it'll tell you it was
wrong or it took too long or it ran out
of memory that sort of thing and then
the neat thing about this is we have
this leaderboard that ships basically
the the top score for each of these
types of metrics not going to go into
too much detail now about how those are
measured because that would take a while
but you can kind of mouse over them to
get get an idea so
No so you wouldn't be able to get like
the top spots solution because then
somebody else could just resubmit it and
maybe get a little lucky
for that like a awl is probably more
ideal for that because that does come
with like an answer key the elementary
introduction to Wolfram language the
book has a bunch of exercises in the
back those have solutions so as you
solve these when you when you visit the
site it'll mark what what you've solved
when you last solved it thanks Cody and
you can see on the leader board whether
or not you show up what we have our
profiles we couldn't we couldn't just
have people's Wolfram IDs displayed
without you know asking them because you
know there could be kids doing this and
all that so everyone starts out called
anonymous and they have a randomly
generated image I'm not going to
generate these for the sake of time
right now but this is what it looks like
this is me you can edit your profile so
if you end up on leaderboard you can
pick what your name will be you can pick
a profile image and if you've done
anything with the cloud cloud deploy
things like that you probably recognize
this as a regular form function so
pretty much everything you see is is
being powered by the cloud underneath
the hood here
nope nope so when a challenge gets
published it's immediately available for
people to submit solutions for so there
can always be someone that submits a
solution that's faster and then maybe
they can beat the speed score but there
are other measurements that maybe when
somebody has no one will ever beat no
they like they last forever yeah yeah so
that that was kind of what challenges is
like for the typical user where they go
through these challenges and they solve
them and they're kind of the consumer of
the site also anyone can contribute a
new challenge if they want to at the
bottom of the site you get this link
download authoring notebook it looks
like this and you can basically fill one
of these out and create the challenge
yourself and you could submit it you
would get reviewed and it gets published
it would appear on the website and
people can start solving it
so you basically define like what the
solution should be what types of things
that's tested on those things aren't
aren't seen by users and then the rest
of this stuff up here like description
more details that's the type of thing
that appears on the website yes
right and this is one of the tricky
things writing challenges is actually
probably more difficult than solving
them because you have to consider things
like let's say your function has to
return a set of numbers that satisfy
some property do they should they also
be sorted for example it's you have to
be really specific about what you're
asking for and if you're not then users
will run into issues where like well my
answer is correct it gets thing asked
for but the authors solution did
something slightly different and it was
it wasn't clear so it is kind of tricky
as not there
you can provide a verification function
it's not documented in this template we
will have a new version of that
authoring up what coming out that will
document that but you can give an
explicit function to compare the two
results to determine if they're
equivalent so you could have like sort
argument one same queue argument two and
if that were true then you would
consider it correct otherwise authors
function with an input uses function
with an input it's just comparing to see
if they're the same but but it's pretty
much unlimited with how much equivalence
do you want to add into that that
function hmm yeah yeah so so if you want
to use like convert everything to
numerical real numbers as opposed to
integers you could do that to consider
them equivalent and then compare that
they're close enough so when someone
does submit one of those we have this
this publishing workflow where it would
appear in here and actually
I'm just going to do this real quick for
an example
so as users you guys wouldn't ever be
able to see this page I'm showing you
kind of how it works in the backend like
how content management goes through so
we have that Solana just submitted I'm
logged in as well from challenges so
it's weird that the admin account is
doing that but there's all kinds of
stuff you can do with it we can view it
I'm not going to do that I can approve
it reject it I'm going to approve it not
connected to VPN so that won't work
this is going to spam email to everyone
sorry
yep yep yes so this page that we're
looking at right now this is just cloud
deploy of delayed of a string template
applied to an association depending on
who's requesting it so here it is and
then we have this this queue of
challenges that are in editing and a
challenge is basically an association of
data that sits in a cloud object and as
we make changes to them and they get
edited as you can see here this is the
history of butterflied strings things
that were done to it these represent
previous states of that challenge and
all this is done with cloud objects and
notebooks and and all that and I'm just
going to go ahead and delete that one
goodbye okay now I need to move a little
faster
so like I was just saying before just so
I can convince you that I wasn't lying
it is just a delayed expression what's
doing here is just doing a cloud get on
a file that basically has all the code
that generates that page so this is that
page we're just viewing this is what it
does we can evaluate it locally and and
this is what it what the response is it
creates an HTTP response and it's a web
page so that page I was just showing you
guys with all those buttons those are
basically just an interface to a whole
bunch of different cloud deployed API
functions like this one there's a button
there buttons to view the changes from
that history I was showing you like what
changed about the challenge as new edits
came in like this one was a title change
his chip good job and it shows like what
data in the metadata was changed that
type of stuff so again it's all a
notebook interface and it's working with
associations that are stored in cloud
objects another example this is how how
we edit them it basically looks just
like the authoring notebook I showed you
except you can submit edits instead and
does it hits a different API instead of
submissions so yeah this is basically
all the stuff that any page was showing
just viewing with the API requests
individually
so that challenge butterflied strings
this is where it lives it's it's just in
a cloud object and this is what lives in
there so it's powered by cloud objects
like I was saying it uses data bin for
tracking submissions to keep like a
long-term storage of things people
submit there's data in here to figure
out how to generate the notebooks from
it but that all just lives in a cloud
object and every time edits are made
edits are moved into a new cloud object
so we retain the history so like I was
saying there's that delayed content
management page and that's basically an
interface to all these API functions but
there's all kinds of other stuff as well
so there's there's a lot of moving parts
to the wolfen challenger site so there's
various things like API functions
delayed scheduled tasks things like that
and one of the things I found really
useful when trying to organize all these
different parts and keeping them
consistent is to basically attach
metadata to everything you deploy like
keep track of your package version that
it was deployed from and I can actually
show that one of these
so the API that actually tests the
solution when I hit that when I
submitted my answer this is this is the
metadata for that now the permissions
are the file in the package it was
defined from and I can quickly check
like what what package version did I
deploy this from when was it deployed
what version of the cloud was it when it
was deployed what version of the cloud
is it now so usually that's something I
watch out for and these no longer match
that means I probably need to make sure
I redeploy some stuff to make sure it's
all well consistent with new cloud
versions so this is just to give you an
idea of like what types of expressions
in there and these are the schedule
tasks and it's tracking the typical
schedule tasks information types of
things so these are some of the
challenges involved with developing
challenges they're very challenging so
when I make changes to the code and the
package where I define all this stuff
how do I know what needs to be
redeployed I have some like 80-something
things that I need to cloud deploy or
cloud put things like that would take a
long time if I had to do every single
one each time how do I know when
something's going wrong what as
developers with Wolfram language we're
mostly used to working with notebooks in
the front end where we evaluate
something we see the output and we make
a decision based on that output like
what do we do next we get an error
message and like up something's wrong
we're not gonna do this next thing until
I figure that out when you deploy an API
function with this big block of code
you're basically sending it off and just
crossing your fingers and hopes it hope
that it does what you expect and that's
that's that's pretty difficult
so so my approach to that was basically
naming all these individual deployments
and and I tracked that the code version
to figure out to make sure if something
is out of date maybe I need to redeploy
it I can quickly check them all right
here and this one is out of date it's
very out of date but it's obsolete and I
just haven't deleted it because I don't
know it's it's something that's not
accessible from the site anywhere your
your definitions so that cloud object I
was shown before that's in delayed the
code that it runs is actually just this
binary deserialize and by dre
I'll explain in a minute why and what
those what those are but all of them are
like this everything I've deployed has a
name goes to this this definitions
folder and gets the named code so one of
the things I figured out pretty early on
is wxf format which is what you get with
binary sierra lives by nor do you
serialize or exporting to wxf that that
can retain some information about
whether or not expressions are
initialized and this is kind of a super
technical example that maybe is a little
weird but this this function
you can't just clad deploy this normally
and have it work which I'll explain
after if anyone has questions about that
so what I mentioned before about the
issue with deploying something and just
hoping it works you never see if
anything's going wrong I'm gonna
this example is purposely simulating an
error in one of my AP eyes it's it's
gonna it'll still work but it basically
goes into a panic mode and it's it's
emailing me right now saying something's
broken it's collecting a stack trace and
logging some information about what
happened and I can look at it because it
saves that information so 15 seconds
that would be right so this is what
happened I have the evaluation data
attract what message was generated this
one a test message was requested says
what what was being evaluated when it
happened where it was evaluated when
what version of the the package it was
what machine it was running on so all
kinds of different metadata which is
super useful in debugging and also saves
a full stack trace so when you're when
you're in the front end with notebooks
you can click the little thing next to
the message and view stack trace and you
can see what what function were being
called and where your error happened
that's not as easy when you're when
you're running an API in a headless
Colonel but there is a way to get that
so this is an example that I can
probably skip over so some of the things
I was just talking about that ways of
dealing with these issues it's one thing
for me to just say oh yeah these are
problems I solved them but it would be
more useful to you guys if you were also
developing something like this and you
wanted to solve these problems as well
these these functions exist and are
available to you as resource functions
which
you will be hearing about these and why
is this not visible
so these are functions and these saw a
lot of these solve the problems I was
talking about I packaged them up from
Wolfram challenges code and and
submitted them to the function
repository which if you guys don't know
what that is yet that's fine just I tend
to talk tomorrow and you'll you'll get
in the full details but most of these
things I talked about our available few
T's there and there are more coming so
you'll definitely want to check that out
and to Wolfram challenges similar sure
for the types of things that Wolfram
language really excels at there's
nothing else even remotely close to the
ability to just take code as data so a
piece of code in Wolfram language is is
equivalent to a piece of data we can
take that code compute stuff with it
Oh using wool from I mean there's the
yeah wloz mentioning before was made by
Wolfram it's Stephen Wolfram's book I
did the API for doing the automated
grading for that but I think so I
yeah
well it depends like are you familiar
with the unit testing framework that
ships with more from language like yeah
so one of these the example I skipped
over is actually that's not the one I
meant so this is like a runtime
assertion type of thing I'm not used to
this keyboard sorry so that just gives
the result if you want to put a
constraint on what you expect that out
to put put to be you can give it as a
second argument here and it'll it'll
it'll fail if it doesn't if it doesn't
match also and you can give a third
argument like throw whatever from some
tag to exit what you were doing so if
you if you were writing a function that
did a bunch of stuff like copying files
and deleting files in each of these
outputs you you know you have some test
some assertion you want to make about
that output and you want to verify that
that is correct so this this could be
for example that
so this this little evaluate copy file
and check that the output is something
that file exists returns true if it's
not it's gonna throw failed which how
could it catch here and that way you can
be sure that it's going to stop right
here if that condition is not satisfied
it's not gonna run this delete file it's
not gonna collect go or it's not gonna
pass go collect $200 and all that you
could basically have these these checks
in place on a step by step basis to kind
of make things safer now that's like
runtime testing so that's during the
evaluation of your function your your
checking to make sure things are
consistent because something like copy
file cloud objects you're doing a web
operation what if there's a network
issue you can't you it's not something
you can fully test and check for at
before deploying the code and be like
okay checks out it's good to go it's
never going to be a problem it's nicer
to have something that checks at runtime
as well so you can basically you know I
could have this throw be a send mail
this failed
for this reason fix it type of thing you
know and that and that's what this does
it it emails me if there's something
wrong in fact I have email sitting my
inbox now because of that test message I
did but so so runtime checking it I
think is very important for for cloud
deployed code and this is mainly for you
know the bigger more complicated stuff
that's that's powering something that
you want to want to make sure it keeps
running and then there's also the
testing framework that comes with so you
think you can create a bunch of
verification tests there's there's a
there's a whole interface built in for
generating these and and you can
basically set up a test suite and
there's something that you want to
periodically run to make sure things are
working the way you expect but like it
like I was saying before you still
always want to be checked checking stuff
at runtime to make sure things are still
working waves
yeah yeah
yes and I've done that actually I
actually have like ten different
deployments on my own encounter
challenges if you had the package that I
wrote which I don't think I can just
yeah yeah so it was it was like actually
it's probably still posted somewhere but
uh
yeah yeah so it would it would be super
simple to make like a separate version
of the site that that didn't track that
and didn't have that question is like
how would we do that as like two
different products everything yeah yeah
I I've actually I've heard that from
somebody else before as well yeah no
that that's something other people
brought up before as well some people
don't like the competitive aspect of it
so it is something we can look at oh we
blurb everything that it's one of the
things we've talked about we don't we
haven't really come to a conclusion but
we were thinking like well one of the
things we could do is for a challenge
after you've solved it you would then be
given a link to a Wolfram community
thread or something where people who
have solved the challenge or allowed to
post there yeah yeah I yeah we just
haven't haven't come up with anything
concrete for that but it is something
we've been talking about yep
no no blocked like not allowed to submit
what should I try
to be honest I don't actually know
that's gonna do there's there's stuff
that's blocked at a low level Oh
your code gives web image search testing
and my phone just vibrated because the
email to me saying something was blocked
and it's probably gonna be something
like a URL fetch down the level that's
not a white listed domain so I have
things like Wolfram Alpha or knowledge
base type things geoserver things those
are all white listed so things like
things to like the data repository
certain URL fetches or writing files
that would be appropriate to caching
resources those are all allowed but you
can't just arbitrarily do something
that'll read or write tiles or fetch
stuff from the internet let's say that
again sorry no this is public welcome
cloud yep yep so so there's nothing
really going on here that anyone
couldn't do if they if they wanted to
put the time into into building
something like this so it's not like
we're using any hidden magic stuff here
it's all it's all public cloud running
so a cloud notebook exists for this
authoring notebook it's not accessible
anywhere because we just haven't really
tested it it might work but right now
we're only officially supporting the the
desktop authoring notebook
yeah it's I actually totally forgot this
existed until you mention that we don't
we don't store much like identifying
information it's stored by things like
Wolfram UUID so it binds to like the
account and things like that but we're
not I think there are things like
geolocation I think would show up based
on some of the data bin operations
things like that but there there's a lot
of things tracked about like the
solutions themselves and things about
like you know the notebook and a lot of
metadata but like personal information
we're not we're not really collecting
that yeah and I can't actually type in
this so yeah submitting submitting the
authoring notebook from cloud isn't
supported you can do that from desktop
though but the solving the challenges
you can do in either and I found the
cloud notebooks are actually a bit more
convenient
yeah and or we actually have a new
version this that isn't there yet so
this this is going to change soon but we
do have a way to provide feedback
directly about challenges coming very
soon
yes yes and in fact I wrote some stuff
for the solution testing for that too
which I have not a hundred percent sure
it's gonna end up being used but I think
some of the stuff I wrote might be
involved in that so I have personal
interest in that yeah you guys should
I'll get that shot and you should also
give some of these challenges a shot
because they're challenging
[Applause]